[Musique]
Michel seoget Geneviève Tellier bonsoir
bonsoir oui nous allons reparler du
troisième lien
interpellation aujourd'hui du Premier
ministre c'est l'étude des crédits à
l'Assemblée nationale je vous fais
entendre un petit extrait sur les
excuses ensuite en Europe pour tous
parce qu'on a été beaucoup question de
la participation du fédéral
et jusqu'à quel point le fédéral ira etc
mais on écoute d'abord les les questions
sur les excuses
la ministre des petits Chutes de la
Chaudière reconnu une promesse
brisée est-ce qu'elle a commis une
erreur de reconnaître
la promesse était faite en fonction d'un
certain nombre de données à partir du
moment où les données sur lesquelles on
se base pour faire une promesse change
ben moi je considère pas que c'est une
promesse brisée
donc ce n'est pas une promesse brisée
dit le Premier ministre Michel seoget
évidemment les oppositions les pôles
hachées aujourd'hui lors de l'étude des
crédits par ailleurs on en a parlé
plutôt monsieur Legault a dit on n'est
pas prêt à donner aucun chiffre aucune
échéancier là ça sera pour plus tard
Michel
oui c'est une promesse brisée monsieur
on a des citations de monsieur legoon a
pu finir en disant j'ai pas besoin
d'études le lien la nécessité du
troisième lien est évidente pour tout le
monde etc et on ne change pas d'idées
sur la construction d'une infrastructure
qui va durer des décennies et des
décennies parce que les chefs de jeudi
passé de voiture sur le pont et parfois
les mêmes ça ça c'est je sais que
Monsieur lebouze retranche derrière ça
et c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait un
gouvernement public on dit pas ah on a
eu les chute sont pas bon c'est pas ça
ne tient pas alors c'est juste qu'il
s'excuse pas à un moment donné la
question c'est sûr qu'on puisse la
promesse puis oui
et si on se porte vers le futur la
question sur le troisième lien restant
avec le transport en commun questionné
par les libéraux puis par Québec
solidaire monsieur Legault a dit le
fédéral sera la hauteur de 40%, et ça
joue dans notre décision
or le député Marc Tanguay lui a dit oui
mais c'est pas illimité le fédéral
m'arrive à steel est-ce que ça c'est
acquis d'après vous que peu importe le
projet il y aura 40% de ce de cette
facture là qui arrive de d'Ottawa
non je ne pense pas que c'est acquis
d'ailleurs la semaine dernière quand on
s'en était parlé quand on a appris que
le projet changeait la réaction était
quand même timide du côté d'Ottawa on
reconnaît que oui il y a pas mal plus de
chances qu'on met de l'argent mais on
dit attendez de voir la mouture finale
du projet parce qu'il a changé plusieurs
fois attendant de voir les études
d'impact environnemental on dit
attendons plusieurs plusieurs choses
donc il y a peut-être prématuré de
d'assumer kotawak couvrira 40% de la
facture quelle qu'elle soit parce qu'on
sait pas combien ça va coûter non plus
oui il y a plus de chance ça ça aide
monsieur le goût avec son projet mais
c'est pas garanti et si je peux me
permettre de dévier un peu aussi je
trouve que Monsieur Trudeau monsieur le
groupe pardon a profité du fait que que
ces députés de Québec n'est pas voulu
étaler leur chicane de famille sur la
place publique soit mais je pense que
Christine Biron peut-être comme il y a
un impair en parlant de retour
d'ascenseur je
lisais la période des questions parce
que je l'ai raté en direct il y a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de questions là-dessus
aussi auxquelles monsieur le goût n'a
pas répondu et j'ai l'impression que
c'est propre député peut-être et
volontairement lui ont fait une petite
jambette là-dessus aussi en parlant de
retour d'ascenseur de projets qu'on
attend à aller vie à Québec je pense que
ça aussi ça risque de le hanter dans le
dossier du troisième lien Geneviève
Tellier elle est les secousses sont
nombreuses ont quand même été fortes et
que monsieur Legault dise une promesse
brisée ou pas en fait peu importe il y a
un effet net dans les je les électeurs
de cette région là
j'ai l'impression que cette promesse
c'est pas juste à propos du troisième
bien c'est vrai que c'est le symbole
c'est l'image qu'on a mais c'était aussi
la promesse je suis là pour les régions
plaquax c'est un parti de région c'est
là qu'il s'est fait élire la région de
Lévis par exemple peut-être important de
la périphérie de Québec et les régions
ont souvent eu l'impression qu'elles
étaient délaissées par les grands
centres et j'ai pas l'impression qu'en
disant on change notre promesse notre
promesse c'est juste à propos du
troisième lien je pense que les gens
dans les régions se disent bon on est
encore abandonnés et ça ça pourrait
effectivement laisser des traces je
comprends un peu le retour d'ascenseur
c'est pas un peu le message qui était là
c'est bon ben si oui on sait sur ça il
va pas falloir nous oublier il va
falloir nous donner quelque chose
d'autre en échange mais qu'est-ce qu'on
peut donner d'autre je dirais pas
beaucoup de solutions ça passe j'aime
bien l'impression par un pont alors
c'est un peu un problème qui est
insoluble mais oui je le vois un petit
peu plus large que juste ce lien se pose
ce tunnel donc
exactement il y a une question de
confiance aussi
de relation de confiance entre le
gouvernement Monsieur Patrice
déjà de la réussite de Québec nous
promener là c'est le royaume de l'état
de Maurette le royaume de la voiture et
de la grosse voiture ces gens-là ne
veulent pas de tunnel de transport en
commun le maire le Houllier qui a une
poutre sa population lui a dit bien
clairement c'est pas ça qu'on veut et
c'est ça
peut-être qu'on va se retrouver quelle
grosse infrastructure qui marche pas
très bien parce que l'autre côté c'est
pas ça qu'ils veulent puisqu'on relevé à
Ottawa aussi juste poursuivre là-dessus
c'était voyons voir qu'est-ce qu'on
propose comme transport en commun parce
qu'à l'heure actuelle l'offre n'est pas
débordante donc est-ce que le projet
justifié dépendamment de l'offre de
transport en commun qui passerait par ce
tunnel là est-ce que les gens vont s'en
servir martine Biron hier sur notre
antenne disait
attendons de voir la elle-même le
sous-texte c'est-à-dire je retiens pas
mon souffle non plus l'avant de
promettre ça mais comme étant à suivre
on revient quelques secondes parenthèses
sur hier l'échange entre Paul
Saint-Pierre Plamondon et monsieur
Legault je vous fais entendre quelques
extraits là-dessus aujourd'hui puis vous
allez me dire ce que vous en pensez
ce qui est pas acceptable une fois que
j'ai gagné mon élection par 2700 votes
sur la cape la question de qu'est-ce qui
serait arrivée si il y avait pas eu de
dépliant elle n'a pas de pertinence en
chambre lorsque je pose des questions
sur le troisième lien on est plus dans
un exercice politique on est dans un
exercice visant à miner la crédibilité
du Premier ministre un lien avec
l'élection d'un collègue député était
indigne et participe de la petite
politique
oui oui
sur le fond c'est des attaques qui sont
personnelles qui sont basses qui sont
pas dignes la fonction de Premier
ministre et surtout c'est un
modus operandi fréquent la de François
Legault
quand on lance des roches
dit qu'on avait des députés qui étaient
pas légitimes à Québec ce que j'ai dit
c'est il était mal placé pour parler de
parce que a-t-il expliqué hier en charme
monsieur Legault Paul Saint-Pierre plat
Mondon son opposant a dû quitter parce
qu'il y avait eu des tracts mis et
enlever par ton des tracts du PQ enlevés
par le candidat de QS bon Geneviève
Tellier est-ce que monsieur Legault ne
marque pas un point en disant le
lendemain écouter de la joute politique
et oui j'ai pas été d'une très grande
gentillesse en même temps ça fait partie
du jeu
alors effectivement je pense pas que ça
a été un très bon moment pour monsieur
Legault ça peut être une bonne journée
ça a été dur puis je pense que c'est
laissé emporter si réfléchit la
prochaine fois il voudra pas faire ça
ceci étant dit on a bien l'impression
que certains c'est amusant d'entendre
Gabriel Nadaud Dubois parlé l'impression
que certains sont capables de le
picasser là donc québécois ça va un peu
où aller le chercher pour le faire
sortir de ses gants donc ça arrive pas
souvent à monsieur Legault mais c'est
arrivé hier puis non je pense que
c'était pas du tout
excusable ou admissible il y aurait pas
dû dire ça monsieur pas Saint-Pierre
il est légitime très certainement et on
fait pas des petites attaques comme ça
deux choses d'abord quand monsieur
Lebois une mauvaise journée il y a une
grosse mauvaise journée
moi je l'ai écrit
aujourd'hui
le dépliant je le dis il a gagné
l'élection elle s'est retirée il s'est
retiré cette candidate là donc
l'élection était légitime et Monsieur
Saint-Pierre flamandro et légitime dans
son rôle de député ça c'est évident il y
a deux choses très différentes là-dedans
puis monsieur Lebeau se sert de ce qui
l'arrange mais bon ensemble tout le
monde tout le monde est égal tout le
monde est député de compter conclusion
Marie l'assure
oui je suis d'accord avec mes collègues
c'était maladroit monsieur Lego s'est
emporté c'était pas la meilleure
réplique à servir à Paul
saint-pierre-la-monan cela dit Paul
Saint-Pierre Plamondon venait de dire à
monsieur Legault que les gens de Québec
etc on fait campagne sur représentation
donc essentiellement on menti aux
électeurs donc je trouve que la question
invitait peut-être un peu une réponse
dans ces eaux là c'était peut-être pas
glorieux de servir ça de réponse à la
perd des questions mais je trouve que
Monsieur Saint-Pierre flamandon a
peut-être l'épiderme un peu sensible je
suis un peu d'accord avec monsieur
Legault que si une attaque dans ce
sens-là est faite au gouvernement ben le
gouvernement réplique dans les mêmes
choses
très bien grève des fonctionnaires
monsieur Trudeau c'était frappant on va
l'entendre ce matin la semaine dernière
il a dit jour 1 il a dit le patience a
des limites jour 1 on est rendu jour 7
Maryse d'ailleurs c'est vous qui avez
posé la question après deux fois et donc
ce matin monsieur le goût monsieur Lego
monsieur Trudeau et a dit ben écoutez ça
négocie tout va bien
on est en train de construire des offres
constructives on a de l'espoir qu'on va
continuer de voir des avancées mais ça
prendra le temps que ça prend j'ai pas
une patience infinie mais je sais que
nous nous avons des avancées de façon
constructive
donc marie puis vous lui voulait faire
marquer mais vous étiez impatience
l'année dernière vous êtes patients
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous comprenez
de ça
c'est bizarre d'être plus d'être plus
impatient aujourd'hui
ce qui était frappant en fait c'est que
Monsieur Trudeau avait l'air plus
disposé à laisser le temps au
négociations de progresser que sa
ministre responsable du dossier
monoforter président du Conseil du
Trésor elle est arrivée au caucus en se
disant frustré que le syndicat lui
ramène sans cesse des offres
déraisonnable monsieur Trudeau lui
disait ça prendrait le temps que ça
prendra donc il semble y avoir peut-être
une perception différente peut-être que
Madame Fortier plus exaspéré parce que
c'est elle qui est à la table de
négociation mais ce que j'ai remarqué
aussi dans les derniers jours c'est que
Madame Fortier est pas toujours aussi
présente qu'avant à la période des
questions par exemple et je me demande
si il commence pas à y avoir une petite
insatisfaction que ça traîne en longueur
sans nécessaire dire que c'est la faute
de Mona Fortier mais je sens que le
gouvernement est peut-être un peu
insatisfait de la teneur ou le de la
tournure des négociations et des débats
publics quant à la patience de Monsieur
Trudeau moi je m'intéresse sur la
patience des fonctionnaires qui à un
moment donné vont peut-être être tanné
d'être payés 75 dollars par jour c'est
pas les postes les plus rémunérés qui
sont en grève et je ne sais pas combien
de temps eux vont avoir envie de
d'attendre Geneviève qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez où on en est
en même temps ça fait des journées où le
gouvernement a pas a versé des salaires
donc d'attendre un peu puis de laisser
passer des journées ça peut être bien
parce qu'après on peut offrir des
augmentations un petit peu plus élevées
donc il y a peut-être un petit peu cette
stratégie là mais ce qui me surprend le
plus puis moi aussi j'étais un peu comme
Marie c'est à dire que je me pose un peu
la question pourquoi ce changement de
tondre monsieur le Trudeau mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il essaie de se mettre
un peu au dessus de la mêlée les mots
sont durs en ce moment alors entre le
syndicat et Mona Fortier les deux
s'accusent de mauvaise foi de mal négoc
on est à la case départ et ça joue dur
ici et donc j'ai l'impression que ce
Trudeau se met un petit peu au-dessus de
la mêlée pour dire NON NON qui était
froid on va régler ça puis il voit
éventuellement peut-être être l'arbitre
d'ailleurs le syndicat interpellé hier
c'est vous qui devient négocier pas
Madame Fortier alors je pense que pour
lui c'est de se mettre en position de
recul mais de toute façon elle va
tacheuse de voir aussi comment ça se
déroule la population est pas si
mécontente que ça non plus oui on parle
de des rapports d'impôts mais il y a pas
encore une grande populaire non plus qui
se manifeste alors il y a peut-être un
peu de temps qui joue quand il Parlement
peut utiliser et on a connu pire pour
les passeports Michel c'est
cette bonne guerre cela dit faut pas
oublier là les rapports d'impôts quelque
chose comme 90% arrive de façon
électronique maintenant alors il y a
personne qui regarde une personne
seulement là c'est pas grave les
passeports c'est pas encore trop grave
mais il est à un moment donné ça va le
devenir ils veulent pas se retrouver
dans une situation de passeport comme
l'autre fois donc il va y avoir une loi
spéciale un de ces jours mais peut-être
pas tout de suite
4,1 milliard je saute à l'autre sujet
pour les langues officielles pour aider
le français qui est menacé au Canada
mais aussi une portion qui ira pour la
langue anglaise en statue minoritaire au
Québec tour de table s'est annoncé
aujourd'hui dans ce plan d'action
Marie je commence avec vous
sur le vin pour cent je suis pas
certaine
si on s'énerve avec raison en fait ce
qu'on dit c'est que 20% c'est la
proportion qui traditionnellement est
réclamée dans des appels de projets donc
ça devrait être dans ces eaux-là mais
que c'est pour de l'aide à l'emploi qui
peut passer par de la francisation et de
l'aide pour le français langue second
donc c'est pas de l'argent pour la
langue anglaise précisément c'est de
l'argent pour les communautés
anglophones cela dit c'est peut-être pas
le message que le gouvernement voulait
donner aujourd'hui je pense qu'ils sont
pas très contents de la couverture mais
ce que je remarque c'est qu'à Québec on
n'a pas l'air particulièrement énervé
donc
je suis pas sûr que ça va faire une si
grosse tempête que ce qu'on présage
aujourd'hui Geneviève un mot là-dessus
ouais mais en même temps il y a pas
d'argent pour les francophones au Québec
puis je pense c'est ça le problème mais
alors je veux bien c'est un programme de
protection des langues officielles donc
c'est protéger les langues qui sont
menacées je suis pas sûr que l'anglais
soit menacé au Québec qu'on veuille
aider les anglophones à apprendre
davantage le français oui c'est bon je
pense que ça ça peut être une bonne
politique mais je pense que ça va être
ça le principal problème du gouvernement
Trudeau c'est dire on reconnaît la
fragilité du français mais en même temps
il y a pas d'enveloppes budgétaire pour
le français au Québec
l'important c'est d'arrêter la fausse
égalité entre l'anglais au Québec et le
français dans le reste du Canada
si Monsieur Trudeau père avait vu ça il
aurait fait une syncope alors donc
l'avancée elle est là après ça les
ratiaux de combien on donne d'argent
puis est-ce que les anglophones Québec
ont besoin d'argent des fois oui parce
qu'ils sont capables de trouver des
profs des choses comme ça mais
vous êtes la révolution là-dedans c'est
le fait qu'on dit il y a une seule
langue qui est menacée au Canada ça
s'appelle le français scolaire ce qu'on
disait pas avant merci beaucoup
Marie-Michelle geneviève a très bientôt
au revoir bonne soirée au revoir au
revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI